I've stabbed people
I've dismembered them I've killed people
in unthinkable ways I've actually
murdered more people on film than any
actor in history but I'm not such a bad
guy this great big story is made
possible by Geico
happy Geico in 15 minutes can save you
15% or more on car insurance
[Music]
I'm Kane Hodder I'm an actor and the
stuntman been a stunt man stunt
coordinator in over a hundred and
seventy films countless number of TV
shows I never really had much
recognition until I played the character
of Jason and Friday the 13th part seven
eight nine and ten when I first put that
hockey mask on as Jason it felt right
based on those performances I was cast
to play Victor Crowley in the hatchet
films the stunt background helped
tremendously in me developing some of
the terrible characters I played at a
weird thing to say in my first year in
the stunt business I had a fire stunt
that did not go as planned I got burned
over half of my body the process in the
hospital was excruciating five and a
half months in the hospital and I was
very depressed and while I was in the
burn unit saw someone come in to visit
the staff who was a former patient and I
saw him looking happy and laughing and
having fun and that completely turned me
around and I started having a much more
positive attitude and I never even met
the guy guys because of that knowing how
much it helps to talk to or see or just
be with someone that has been burned
themselves
I try to visit people and burn units as
often as I can because it was crucial in
my recovery so if I can help somebody
the same way I'm happy to do so one of
my favorites I've ever done at first
when I started doing horror conventions
I think people were kind of surprised
that given the characters that I have
played that I was actually a nice guy
pretty much any actor will tell you the
people that play the most horrific
violent characters those are the people
that are very nice in real life it's
rewarding and somewhat exciting to know
that I strike fear in the people's
hearts hopefully that doesn't come off
strange but that's the whole point
if your performance evokes emotions in
the audience than you've succeeded
people tell me that they were terrified
that certain things that I did and I'm
like good that's how I was supposed to
be
[Music]